Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
continuing in alwaj
in the opening
chapters of salah the book of salah.
Yesterday we discussed
what the author took us to which was the
importance of salah and Salah's position
in Islam.
The author then mentions the dangers
of an individual abandoning salah. We've
got a few scenarios here.
We've got someone who prays
regularly on time properly
misses a prayer here and there.
Another scenario, someone
who prays off and on. They have starts
and stops. Another scenario of
someone who prays occasionally
but usually does not pray.
And then finally someone who does not
pray at all. We say they don't pray at
all. meaning in general they are not
someone that makes salah unless
there's some occasion and they happen to
be at the right place the right time
this is a very dangerous
thing a Muslim
playing with his or her salah
is one of the most dangerous things
for any human being
because salah is so incredibly important
and so integral
that the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
referred to it as
in the narration of Muad in in others.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam
referred to prayer as the centermost
pillar of a tent. If you imagine Islam
as a tent,
the
you know the pillar that is set up in
the very middle that keeps the entire
canopy up. This is the example that he
gave and the analogy of salah
with respect to its relationship to the
rest of a person's Islam with Allah.
You know when the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam gives us
gives us imagery in the way that he
speaks to us. So he says for instance
Islam has been built upon five pillars.
What is the imagery we get in our mind?
Imagery of a building. Correct. That's
very intentional because when a person
begins his journey and his path to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, from the moment
that he steps onto the path,
he is now actively building
a proverbial
house of worship.
He is actively building a proverbial
house of worship
between himself and Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. He is essentially
building his relationship no differently
than a person builds a physical
building.
And there are things which are extras in
any building, right? paint, like
fixtures in the walls,
electricity and indoor plumbing and all
of these fancy things. I mean, these are
kind of important now, but you know,
they used to be fancy.
these things
are of various positions.
All of them are of course necessary. All
of them, of course, important, but
having nice paint on the walls or nice
carpet
is not the same level of importance
as having a foundation to the actual
building and not just building it
plopped on top of the ground, right? is
not the same
having, you know, nice trim trimming
around the walls and
you know
decorations and furniture is not the
same as the pillars that keep up the
literal ceiling over a person's head.
These are very different things with
respect to how necessary they are, how
important they are, how integral they
are. Some of these things you remove
them, it makes the house or the building
ugly. Some of these things you remove
them it makes them it makes the building
that you're attempting to build that is
your relationship with Allah it makes it
you know unsightly
distasteful
some of them makes it inhospitable and
uncomfortable
and some of these things if they're
missing they are downright dangerous.
Why are they dangerous? They're
dangerous to the person.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala cannot be hurt
by any of his creation.
He says subhanahua
regarding the disobedience of benel.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala that their
disobedience, their rebellion, their
outright disbelief,
they did not oppress us. Rather, they
oppressed their own selves with these
actions.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is far too
great
than to
be harmed
by any of his creation. harmed.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala be him.
[Silence]
It's different. Harm is very different
than annoyance.
Annoyance, yes. The human being can
become a pest, a nuisance to his creator
as Allah has affirmed in the Quran. But
harm, no, we could never harm Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala. We can deal with
Allah in a harmful way, but ultimately
that harm comes back on who? On us. Now,
why is some of these things so lethal?
If I were to build a house
and when I build this house, you
know, I say, you know, foundations,
they're overrated, right? pillars.
They're overblown. Who needs them? Plus,
they're very expensive. They take a lot
of effort.
Let's go ahead and nicks on the
foundation,
right? Or let's go ahead and instead of
digging deep to set our foundation,
let's just dig six, seven inches,
right?
And if we hit any
hard spot, just skip it, right?
Or if I need at least five pillars to
keep this ceiling above me,
then
you know, we could do with three. We
could do with two. What will happen? And
I want to go and live there as soon as
any storm comes through. Soon as any
inclement weather comes through,
this will fall right on top of my head,
the occupant's head.
When a person builds a flimsy
relationship relationship, a flimsy
house of worship between himself and
Allah,
he is in danger.
And the danger is that it looks
formidable,
but there's no foundations.
There's not enough pillars.
And so any tragedy, crisis, difficulty
comes through or worse, death.
The time when I really need this
desperately more than anything.
I didn't spend my time building that
building. I spend my time, you know,
doing other things and looking at it and
saying, "Well, look how big it is. It'll
be fine." And then when there's no time
left, it falls on a person's head. You
cannot build your house during the
storm. That's not how it works. If we
saw a man outside building during a a
tornado ripping through, said, "What are
you doing? Get inside." See, I'm
building a house real quick so I can get
inside from the storm. We would call
this person insane. We call this person
either extremely silly or something is
wrong with him. However, go to the
hospital.
You will see
rows as far as the eye can see of white
beds with bodies strewn about on these
beds, moaning and groaning, twisting and
turning at the threshold of death,
scrambling to build their house while
the storm is hitting. That's exactly
what you'll see. There is no difference.
You cannot you cannot prepare for the
test while the test is happening. You
cannot build your house while the storm
is hitting. You had all this time to
build it. What were you doing?
And so it becomes so important
for us to focus when Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala or when the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam uses words and analogies
that elicit a particular set of images
in your mind. That is very that is very
that is very deliberate. When he says
Islam has been built upon five pillars,
the images that you get in your mind
with the word pillars and built and
Islam,
these are very deliberate images
that this is what you're going to occupy
for the rest of eternity. This house
that you build.
So these are the pillars.
You can get by without some carpet. You
can get by without fancy paint. You can
get by. It doesn't mean you'll be
comfortable. Notice the words I'm using.
You can get by meaning you won't die
during the storm if you don't have
carpet or wallpaper.
But you cannot get by without a pillar.
You cannot get by without foundations.
And this is exactly the preaching that
people are that some Muslims
are carrying or propagating when they
say things is very easy. Everyone
knows. All Muslims knowhed. There's
nothing difficult about it. Right? You
can learn it in five minutes.
That's saying I only need about
three inches for my foundations.
Or
you know, Allah is most forgiving.
Allah,
yeah, sure, I don't pray. I don't fast,
but Allah knows my heart. That's like
saying this building is going to keep be
held up by duct tape and prayer without
the pillars being set.
This is very dangerous.
And so perfecting our prayer
is extremely serious.
And these narrations that the author
mentions
are the narrations of that same prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. The one who taught
us that Allah is forgiving. The one that
taught us that Allah is merciful. The
one that taught us that Allah will
overlook and pardon. The one that taught
us that Islam is built upon five
pillars. He said other things about this
subject as well.
And these narrations to come are what he
said regarding those who fail to secure
these foundations or fail to
build these pillars properly before
putting a roof over their head. We will
begin these tomorrow inshallah.
[Arabic recitation]